what i want to do in this video is think
about the relationship between variables
and then think about what the graph of
that relationship should look like so
let's say in these two axes let's say on
the horizontal axis over here i i plot
the price of a product
and let's say in this vertical axis
right over here i plot the demand for a
product and i'm only plotting the first
quadrant here because i'm assuming that
price can only be positive and i'm
assuming that the demand can only be
positive that people aren't going to pay
someone to take the product away from
them so let's think about what would
happen for the price and demand for most
normal products so
if the price is low
you would expect that a lot of people
are willing to buy that thing they're
like oh it's a good price i would like
to buy it so if the price is low then
the demand would be high so maybe it
would it would be some place over here
all the way that you would have really
high demand if the price was zero so if
the price was low the demand would be
high now what happens is the price so
right here the price is low demand is
high if price were to go up a little bit
maybe demand goes down a little bit
right price went up a little bit demand
went down a little bit if price went up
a little bit more maybe demand goes down
a little bit more as if price went up a
bunch then demand would go down a bunch
and so the line that represents the how
demand relates to price might look
something like this
might look something like this and i'm
just going to assume for this video that
it's a line it might not be a line it
might be a curve it might look something
like that or it might look something
like that but in general if someone were
to ask you if you they you saw this
magenta curve there that as price
increases what happens to demand you
just say well look price increases as
price increases what happens to demand
well demand is
demand is decreasing now let's think
about a different scenario
let's imagine that we're talking about
the demand for real estate
for actual property and let's say that
on this axis we plot the population
the population in the area and then this
is right over here this is demand
for
demand for land
so when the population is very low you
could imagine if the population is zero
there's no one there who even want to
buy land so the population is very low
the demand is going to be very low and
as population increases demand should
increase if the population grows a
little bit more people are going to want
to buy land and if the population goes
up a bunch then a lot of people are
going to want to buy land so you would
see a line that looks something like
this and once again i drew it as a line
it doesn't have to be a line it could be
a curve of some kind it could be a curve
that looks like that or curve that maybe
it looks like that we don't know but the
general idea is that if someone were to
show you a graph that looked like this
and said how does as population
increases what happens to demand well
you'd say look this is population
increasing what happens to demand demand
is going up here as price increased
demand went down here's population is
increasing demand went up and you could
just make that more general with
variables we're talking about specific
cases here but if i were to plot
something like this
if i if you were to see a graph that
looked like
that looked like that and this is the
variable x and this is the variable y
and somewhere to ask you what happens to
y as x increases
as x
increases
well you take any any x that's that's
the y that we're at for that x and as
you increase x as you move in the
positive horizontal direction as you
increase x what's happening to y
y is going up so for this example as x
increases
y is increasing
if we had a graph that looked like this
let's call that the a axis and this is
the b axis and maybe our graph went like
this
and you say what happens as a increases
as a increases
so if you pick it if you pick an a right
over here we're at that a and that b
right over there as a increases what's
happening to b
well as a increases our point of the
line is now going down our b is lower as
b a increases here b is
decreasing
so just want to give you a general idea
when x and y increase together the the
the line goes from the bottom left to
the top right we would call this an
upward sloping line we would say this
has a positive slope when x increases
and y increase when every time x
increases y also increases is upwards
sloping positive slope when our
independent variable increases and our
dependent variable decreases when the
independent variable is increasing then
you say it has a downward slope or
negative slope and we go from the top
left to the bottom right